all right Yolanda yeah Yolanda where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally I was born in Las Vegas
Nevada I moved to LA when I was one
years old
tell me about your family parents uh my
mother died when she was 16 years old I
was five months uh my dad I never knew
him until I was about nine years old
who raised you my grandmother and my
auntie
how was your how was your childhood with
that my childhood was pretty good it was
good I went to Catholic school I was an
honors student I was valedictorian
cheerleader Girl Scout brownies
um
I did ballet I did tap I took tennis
class ice skating I did everything I
actually lived a rich life I thought we
were rich but we actually you know
worked yeah it sounds like a great
childhood yeah I had a beautiful
childhood
but then you're staying here on Skid Row
today excuse me but you're on Skid Row
today I almost get broke today how'd
that happen uh well
um and when I was growing up I was about
13 years old and I just I met my dad I
went to Las Vegas and met my dad and so
he had got remarried to a lady she had
two kids uh I had a stepbrother and
sister and I wanted to move with him
because I thought you know it'd be cool
moved down there to Las Vegas with him I
was going to high school down junior
high school down there and um
he start he him and my stepmother
started smoking crack cocaine and
everything just went crazy
um he used to beat me every day he still
beat us we I used to go to school with
bruises and marks on my body I never
dressed off a PE because I was you know
didn't want to
people to see my bruises and um
uh uh he used to sell you know we used
to me and my stepsister used to go to a
friend of his house named Tony and he
used to sell us to Tony so he could have
you know get his drugs and we just have
to sleep with Tony and do things with
him and then my dad uh actually gave me
my first hit of crack cocaine when I was
14 years old
um
he said after that I had got pregnant
when I was 17 years old in Las Vegas and
my dad
didn't like the guy I got pregnant with
he so he beat me up one day really bad
and then he raped me
um I was psyched five months pregnant he
raped me
um
after he raped me I'll move back to LA
with my grandma
and um he used to call and threaten me
and tell me he was going to kill me and
everything and
I just you know nothing ever happened so
when I was 17 I was just going through a
lot of stuff after I had my baby my
auntie she was really on crack cocaine
she was on drugs really bad and um so I
started smoking Primos with a friend of
mine
um
after that I got turned on
hanging out with her she started smoking
crack on the pipe and then I tried it
and I started smoking I've been smoking
crack cocaine since I was 19 years old I
have four kids I had three girls and one
boy
um later on my kids they grew up they
never took my kids to social workers or
anything my kids my grandmother and my
aunt raised my kids they lived a good
life they didn't work wrong for anything
I was always there but I wasn't there
because I was on drugs but I was there
um 2000 and um nine my youngest daughter
Yolanda
was uh murdered she was stabbed by a
lady in a wheelchair
she was 16. she had just signed with
Sparks she was going to play with them
she's a basketball star straight A
student she was my you know my my baby
um it's me and the lady in the
wheelchair we have been friends uh
before she got in a wheelchair but after
she got a wheelchair me and her had
conflicts because she started messing
with a guy that I was messing with so
she wanted him really bad so she
threatened to kill everybody in my house
um one day and um
I called 9-1-1 let him know that she had
threatened us and everything they didn't
do anything about it so later on that
day my daughter came home from school we
all were hanging out something happened
so my we ran we we went through it and
we went down on our way to the gas
station we seen the lady in the
wheelchair my daughter approached the
lady in a wheelchair and the lady
stabbed my daughter in the chest
she turned around she said Mommy the
lady just stabbed me I didn't see your
knife I didn't see anything
but all I could see is blood just coming
down on my daughter's mouth
she fell in my arms
uh the ladies in the wheelchair's mom
stabbed me in in my head
um
and in my chest I was stabbed twice my
daughter was stabbed once my daughter
died in my arms she
she was looking at me and she said Mommy
it hurts and I couldn't do anything she
said please don't let me die and there's
nothing I could do nothing and
I was like just go you know losing it so
she didn't actually die from the stab
when she got to the hospital on the way
to the hospital she died from she had
five heart attacks but it's nothing that
they could do
and ever since 2009 I've been homeless
because
I just thought it was my fault and I
didn't want to live no more
but I started smoking crack more and
more and more
limited intense
turning tricks and doing things that I
never did before
um my other kids they took it really
hard too my uh my daughter she has eight
one of my my oldest daughter
she's um
she she's she's lost it she's been in
and out of jail dealing with this my
other daughter that was really best
friends with my with the daughter that
killed she goes through she has eight
kids now but she's dealing with it she's
doing real good but me I just can't
forgive myself because I was on I'm
I couldn't be there for my baby you know
and I feel it's my fault and my son
chosen he lives in Las Vegas now which
he's uh
going to court now for murder
and um
I can't be there for him because I'm on
drugs I'm down here on schedule because
I'm still trying to deal with my
daughter getting killed it's like I see
this every day it had in my sleep I see
it I see it just happening every day it
was something that I could avoid it
because it's because of me I felt like
it was my fault but everybody says it's
not but I do I can't forgive myself for
it
you know she was my everything she was
my namesake she had my name she was
looked like me she was just me and I
just can't forgive myself until today to
crack when I smoke crack I it relieves
me from feeling that fault
but when I come down I go I'm just I
have to have drugs every day I have to
smoke every day just to kill the pain
I've tried to go to rehabs I've been to
12 rehabs I can't do it I just can't do
it and
um
I just
can't do it my grandmother died the year
after she was my everything she died
from a broken heart because she loved my
daughter so much we lost her the next
day I we lost her the next year my
auntie she's she's down here also she's
on drugs really bad
um my kids still love me my my other
kids I have left they still love me they
respect me a lot my daughter went to
eight kids she's always she's she's
there for me I I hang around my
grandkids they love me but I just want
to get rid of the crack I can't take it
years ago I was on a prostitution I've
done everything uh uh I've been raped
and I I mean I've been
almost you know I've been
beating all my relationships are violent
I get into all my teeth are going right
now because the boyfriend I had
he didn't want me to leave I wanted to
leave so he knocked all of my teeth out
I've been out of my eyes I've been
everything I've just been through so
much health and it's like I just won't
stop smoking cracking
it seemed like the crack is my
everything is my boyfriend it's my
husband it's everything because it
doesn't I feel like it doesn't do me
wrong but then when I look in the mirror
now I see myself and I have no
no no
teeth I have no my skin is getting this
and I'm getting older and I see the
crack doesn't like me so lately I live
in the Wine Garden now I'm trying to get
my life together but it's not easy on
skid row it's like when you come out all
it is is drugs so you can't really get
sober
but I'm trying my hardest you know I
just miss my daughter I just
just miss my family I just miss a whole
lot of things I'm just tired of myself I
have four stage cancer in my uterus
I can't have sex
I can't keep a relationship because I
can't have sex because it hurts it's
very painful
um I won't even go to the doctor to get
to see what's going on with me I'm gonna
go to the dentist to get teeth I won't
do anything these drugs just have me
like don't want to do anything but get
high every day
every day
um I wasn't raised like this you know
um I just think you know I don't know
what to do
I just just you know my kids aren't one
of my daughters is on crystal she's
really lost on it she lost all her kids
five of them are going to the system and
I'm the grandma it just everything that
I could have prevented I didn't because
of crack cocaine I feel like
um
like I tell myself I try to tell my
grandkids I said it's not what you do
it's how you do things and why you do
things and you have to think before you
do things you have to think about
yourself and people that love you
because the people that you hurt them
more
and when you hurt them more that's more
on you the more you want to use so now
I'm looking at life in a perspective I'm
trying to get it together
you know um
right now I'm looking like this but I
dress every day I keep myself up but I
don't keep myself up to try to look nice
for everybody else I keep it up for me
you know I keep it up because I know
that I could be better than this
and I'm going to get better of this I'm
going to beat this I'm going to win I'm
53 years old I've been smoking
Corrections
42 years
42 years that's a long time when you
think about it it's time for me to stop
you know it's time me to get my life
together because I want to do other
things I want to be a great grandma
which I'm always I'm there for my
grandkids they love me to death I want
to be the mother that I wasn't
I want to be me you know it's and I want
my daughter that's resting in heaven I
want her to forgive me that's all I just
want her to forgive me I see her face
every day every time I do things every
time I smoke if I comb my hair if I look
in the mirror when I'm asleep I just see
her face every day and she looks at me
she's like Mommy please just stop and I
haven't stopped you yet and now I'm
losing my son he might be going to
prison for a life murder I've lost my
other daughter she in jail now I don't
know what to do but
it just hurts everything just hurts I
just give advice to the kids now just
look for it don't let anything nobody
change you to you it's all about you if
you try to please other people if you
try to
make other people happy
you can't be happy but me I like making
other people happy because it makes me
happy okay I don't try to buy friendship
I don't try to fit in or none of that
I'll just be me now even when I'm doing
drugs I'll be me that's all I can be
I've been through so much abuse in my
life it's just ridiculous you know and
it hurts but I have to deal with it it's
over with now I got to look forward
forward and see what's going to happen
but I don't want to die on Skid Row
I don't want to get to hold to fentanyl
I don't want to be under a white sheet I
don't want to be under a white tent I
just want to stay alive I just want to
be me and all I want out of life is my
daughter rest in peace Yolanda to
forgive me
or putting her into something that she
had nothing to do with
what Yolanda it's easy to blame drugs
for your situation and everything that's
happened right to you and your daughter
and your son but how much of it is the
environment the the neighborhood you
guys grew up in when we I grew up in the
jungles in the jungles it was a lot I we
used to sell drugs and we used to
you know do drugs it was I was all I
grew up around wearing drugs and abuse
my auntie my uncle used to be my auntie
when I was growing up I used to see that
my grandfather used to beat on my
grandmother I seen that I grew up with
brown domestic violence I grew up around
drugs but this was later in my life when
I was younger it was all right I grew up
in a peaceful then all of a sudden when
the drugs came in to my auntie and my
uncles it just things just turned around
but drugs is a it is a big influence to
messing up your life period you know
um mine anyway you know I think if I
never would have started smoking I went
with my dad and started using drugs or
going through what I went with him and
just stayed with my grandmother and my
auntie in L.A I think I would have been
a better person you know I would have my
kids I probably still have my daughters
today
yeah you know I just
you know blame myself for everything
that's happened in my life
you know
um
uh because I grew up I grew up you know
a princess you know my grandmother my
auntie gave me everything and then when
I got on drugs I started stealing from
them and I started disrespecting my
grandma and I started
just doing things that I wasn't raised
to do
today my auntie she she's on drugs but
she she got more she has more control of
her addiction but she blames me she
lives in the place and she always blames
me for everything every time I see her
she's like you know you why do you think
things went bad for you because it
sounds like you had a pretty perfect
childhood right moving with my dad I
think moving like that the abuse that he
gave me because I've never experienced
it with my grandmother and my auntie the
abuse uh the rape
the verbal abuse the physical abuse
everything I blame him really I don't
blame him but that's what I blame that
my life turned out really bad
is that your biggest regret is that is
your biggest regret yes my biggest
regret moving to myself yes getting
involved my dad
my auntie used to tell me oh your dad is
the reason your mom passed away because
she's the my mom after she gave birth to
me I'll swap you know little baby she
used to walk in the rain barefooted and
around looking for my dad because he
used to be with other women and she used
to look for him because he's supposed to
be at home and you know with her and it
was you know
it was crazy she said you know so she
had got you know walking pneumonia she
died and my dad was like when they had a
funeral without he was having a funeral
I was five months old uh my grandmother
went to his mom and told me well you
know Yolanda needs some clothes for the
funeral and everything and they're like
we're not buying anything for yes you
know we're not buying anything for her
so my grandmother actually had to put a
gun on them and told him if you don't
have her something to wear by this
funeral you know I'm gonna hurt somebody
so the next day she came by like they
had me shoes a dress they had everything
but my dad never really claimed me until
I was 99 years like nine to ten years
old
and you know
he you know I don't know he's just
abusive he raped me he also after I left
and came back he raped me and came back
to LA he raped my stepsister
um
and my step sister got pregnant by the
guy I got pregnant by her so we're like
we have kids her kid her son is my uh
daughter's stepbrother and cousin and
I'm like you know wow so
what do you think the answer is all of
this
um is there a solution to this problem
good your story is not not the only one
I've heard like this I know my the
solution for me I'll catch up for
everybody else me is prayer and I just
need to stop using I need to think about
Yolanda now instead of thinking about
everybody else and blaming myself for
everything that happened and just
realized that it wasn't my fault that's
what I really need to realize that it
wasn't me it wasn't my fault you know I
can't blame it on the drugs also it was
just that
it was
just the way life go you know was going
it was a test for me but I haven't I
haven't passed the test yet I just need
to leave the drugs and all every time I
have a good relationship with a man I
get a good man he's not using drugs he
wants to take care of him he wants to
help me but but the drugs always I'm
always
you know move in and not like I'm not
ready to settle down so I lose them and
then I'm out here again by myself I just
because they've been in a tent uh on
Winston and it's amazing how these drugs
make you just don't care about life
period because I'm in a tent it's
storming raining the rain I'm gonna tip
the rain is up to here I'm actually in
Rain sitting in there smoking crack but
I'm drowning there's I'm not it's like
the drowning drowning I'm up to my net
you know I'm the Tim was small but I'm
up to my knees in water but I don't care
as I have my hit notice my lighter
doesn't get wet nose my throat don't get
wet long as I can still get that that
feeling you know I just didn't care and
it's weird it just it's ridiculous you
know I don't I wasn't raised like that
I'm just like
what the hell's going on you know with
the drugs is not that good
in your life what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your life
to love your family to be with your kids
to love your kids to listen to your kids
to go to Every program activity
everything that they have when they want
to talk to you listen to them because
when they're gone and when they are gone
it's a whole different thing it's a
whole different feeling Yolanda used to
always say mommy she should be you know
basketball star you know and she's like
Mommy come to my you know come to the
game I'm playing this weekend you know
I'm like okay I'm coming I get this
smoking crack I don't make it so she
asked me again and again and again so
one day I finally made it to one of her
games and she was playing and they won
she got the highest points but at the
end of the game she was crying so the
lady was like what's wrong with Yolanda
and everybody is listening to this
everybody in the in the in the
auditorium like what's going on my mommy
finally came to my game
and I just broke down to tears and she
just Mommy I love you and you know just
hug me and everything and she's always
tell me stuff you know like a couple of
weeks before she got killed she she said
tell me um because the guy that I was
dealing with and the girl you know it
was like a three me him and her you know
thing and she was like just leave him
alone Mommy and do you you know I'm
saying you're beautiful I love you and
just don't don't don't don't even mess
with that lady don't move that's the
lady that killed her she said don't mess
with the lady and just do your mom just
come hang out with me because you don't
know how good I am I am so good she said
I am she said what she said I am the
business and I'm like what are you
talking about she's saying mom you need
to check it out I am the business I'm
gonna take you out of the jungles you
Grandmama take my family up out of here
playing basketball
so you know two weeks later
and Yolanda never was really close to me
but we were close but she never slept
with me or you know she really didn't
like me kissing her you know because she
was uh she liked girls or whatever she
was a tomboy so just did this this this
one time she slept with me on the couch
I slept in my grandmother and she slept
and went in and I stepped and she held
my feet and she slept with me for two
weeks and I never realized you know what
was really you know what was going on
and we were so close for those two weeks
hmm I miss her so much
she just
I don't know I just know last all I
could see is the last thing she said to
me was not mommy don't let me die and it
was like now here I go again I'm on
drugs I can't do nothing I can't go to
the games I can't I can't talk to her I
can't help her with her homework I can't
do anything and now this big this is the
moment of can you do this for me and I
let her down again
I'm dying inside everybody just don't
know I I I'm I'm really crazy I'm like
don't want to kill myself but I don't
want to live because the pain of of it
it hurts so bad to know that I am the
reason that my daughter is not here is
because I'm a man and the situation that
I couldn't could have waited my mind
just
being sober I could have thought it
thought better the way I could have
talked to the lady and told you know or
something
I just missed my baby I just miss her so
much I miss her so much she missed my
everything she was I love all my kids
all my kids are beautiful I love my son
I love my daughters I love them all and
we all were close I grew up with my kids
like we were teenagers you know almost
really like their sister more than I am
named Mama but we real close like me and
my daughter Teresa there was eight kids
me and her are we're real close and my
grandkids they love me to death but
there's nothing that can replace Yolanda
I just cannot get over
the day I just can't believe that my
baby was gone you know and
I don't mean you know it was like when I
knew she was gone when I really realized
that she was wrong is after the funeral
when they put the casket back inside the
rehearsed and drove away
and I was like
you know my kids are like Mommy yeah
like she's not coming back
and she you're not coming back and I
just wanted to come back I used to wait
for her at her school after she got
killed I used to go to Dorsey I used to
sit out in the front of the school and
the kids would come out and they would
get out of school they like they call me
Mommy too like Mommy what you who you
waiting for I said wait for you I'm
waiting for Yolanda to come out and
they're like why is she not coming out
let's take you home I'm like no you're
not I'm waiting for her she's gonna come
I just sit outside and on the steps wait
for her to come home from school
I have to do I said it's all kinds of
things and
I just can't get over it I still can't
get over it I'll never never that day
will never end for me
[Music]
thank you so much you're still young
though oh yeah I am you still can do
whatever you want yeah I can